I'm in LA for my final surgery to have
my face more arms done I'm finally gonna
be that skinny mama G that I've always
see myself as the transformation begin
now this is the end of it
Gianna was exciting enter your journey
so are you able to like talk after
surgery messed up I'm really nervous
about neck surgery I'm not gonna be able
to come out to eat the tall it's my face
if something goes wrong it is like I can
hide it then there's gonna be no photo
shoot or me going to sugars wedding good
morning Joon are you looking on
sophisticated a everday how only do the
starters gonna take I think I think the
face will take three three and a half
and the arms will take maybe two I mean
I'm ready to start you ever with and
remove my turkey neck but I'm kind of
gonna miss my turkey neck it's more
famous than I am
[Music]
we're gonna get rid of these guys we're
gonna liposuction a little bit so I get
rid of more skin and then on the face
we're just gonna go like that I'm gonna
be able to find you under there okay
you're gonna do great right when you're
on the table everything changes
everything shifts so the marks that I'm
putting on your skin
will really dictate what I do in the
operator don't make him to live first
couple weeks you're gonna be all wrapped
up from your arms up this'll be will as
is he gonna like break your jaw no it
sounds terrible major thing I concerned
with is nerve damage so when I see a
post operatively that's gonna be one of
the first things I checked